get ready because google cloud next
starts today on a virtual screen near
you yes that means you can keep your
sweats on and we're going to start each
morning with a live broadcast and
keynote there will be two channels to
join that play simultaneously so feel
free to switch between them it's up to
you to explore our live interactive
expert q as breakout sessions and demos
check out our expert playlists including
mine or make your own at g dot co slash
cloud slash next as for day one check
out the opening keynote our ceo
tomskirian will talk about how our
products have helped customers adapt to
complexities and challenges and lead to
opportunities i can't reveal too much
just yet but expect to hear about our
biggest launches captivating customer
stories and tk's view on google cloud's
feature keep an eye out for some
exciting cameos as well
then join me in my keynote data cloud
simply transform with the universal data
platform vp of databases and analytics
joins me as we introduce the future of
data analytics and ai at google cloud
we'll highlight our latest technology
for products including bigquery spanner
looker and vertex ai and don't miss it
because there will be a live demo check
out the live q a afterwards to interact
with us
then we'll move into our workspace
spotlight how it's done with google
workspace where they'll announce
launches that are helping customers
transform collaboration and support
genuine human and connection in a hybrid
world and yes there will be a live demo
and q a and the day will wrap up with a
spotlight session on diversity equity
and inclusion to help you build a safe
inclusive and diverse workforce that
thrives and innovates check out channel
2 for partner customer innovation and
dei spotlights featuring our partners
like [ __ ] accenture and deloitte i do
want to also remind you that we have a
bunch of interactive events like q a's
and learning pathways for cloud
infrastructure ai or security and if
you're like hey skip all the talking i
just want to see some live demo action
then filter in the right filter bar in
the catalog and you'll find the sessions
with live demos then add them to your
own custom playlist okay so get ready
for day one and connect on social by
tagging google cloud next and reach out
to me at stefar underscore wong